a origem da palavra trabalho remete ao
latim que vem da palavra tripalium grid
três para um de madeira e na antiguidade
tripalium significava literalmente
tortura era um instrumento de tortura
essa é a origem do que nós fazemos um
trabalho tortura bem o conceito evoluiu
na qualidade média ele foi aprimorado
para o conceito de exercer uma atividade
fim
então você gastar algum esforço você ter
11 é alguma atividade laboral mas
geralmente com restrição de liberdade
então eram os escravos eram os artesãos
camponeses que tinham que trabalhar para
sustentar os patrícios e à sociedade em
geral
o conceito de trabalho passou por mais
uma revolução no renascimento em que
tornou se mais próximo daquilo que a
gente conhece hoje
então esse trabalho importante esse
trabalho que a gente pode ser no bc por
meio dele é um conceito e do século 14
que veio se desenvolvendo até hoje
e essa nova idéia de que o trabalho deve
ser uma coisa que a gente goste de fazer
o que a gente tem que ser feliz fazendo
é tão recente quanto a minha geração se
nós dos 20 aos 30 anos perguntarmos para
os nossos avós
se eles eram felizes trabalhando
provavelmente a gente vai ganhar alguns
olhares atravessados do tipo que tem a
ver em fim todos nós temos uma relação
direta com o trabalho desde quando a
gente nasce que já eram geralmente nasce
pelas mãos de uma parteira de um médico
então a gente se relaciona com o
trabalho direto e indiretamente desde
que a gente nasce
isso é uma coisa intrínseca à vida
humana e se é verdade que a gente pode
estar neste momento se relacionando com
o trabalho de três maneiras distintas
a gente pode estar feliz no nosso
trabalho
a gente pode estar infeliz com o nosso
trabalho de novo o que importa porque
trabalho e felicidade são duas coisas
diferentes
bem nesse caso como estão distribuídas
as pessoas engajadas
as pessoas dizem cajados do trabalho do
mundo né
segundo uma pesquisa é da gala feita em
mais de 142 países 87% das pessoas no
mundo não estão engajados no seu
trabalho
nove em cada dez pessoas no mundo não
estão engajados no seu trabalho
e dessas 24% estão literalmente
sabotando as empresas em que trabalham
elas estão remando contra as empresas
entre elas trabalho então um grupo de 10
você vai pegar aquele um que é a pessoa
motivada
aquelas duas só querem estragar o
negócio e oeste no meio do caminho que
vai nos rascunhos churrasco de outro na
américa latina não é muito melhor
somente 21% das pessoas que trabalham
estão ativamente engajadas naquilo que
fazem
o cenário consegue piorar ainda mais o
setor bancário de 93 e 2005 253 pessoas
se suicidaram com temas relacionados ao
trabalho somente no brasil
253 pessoas tiraram a própria vida com o
tema relacionado ao trabalho
isso vai desde carga excessiva de
trabalho a ociosidade a cobrança de
metas que são inatingíveis relações
sociais muito superficiais
as chefs muito autoritários esses são
todos os temas levantados na pesquisa da
fgv que levaram as pessoas a se
suicidarem 93 e 2005 no setor bancário
mas é verdade não consigo entender o que
leva uma pessoa seja motivada porque eu
tenho uma relação com o trabalho desde
muito jovem né
minha mãe sempre foi muito trabalhador e
meu pai e todos que me cercavam então o
trabalho pra mim sempre foi uma coisa
muito importante e eu não conseguia
entender como raios uma pessoa fica
motivada
eu tinha aquela famosa regra de ouro né
não está feliz
vaza
sai do trabalho que você tá se não faz
sentido pra você procure outro lugar eu
falava isso em tudo quanto é lugar onde
eu ia falar essa questão de vai procurar
a felicidade vai procurar o que satisfaz
falava isso no ensino técnico falava
isso na escola falavam em casa falavam
eu trabalhava
este problema as pessoas não sabiam elas
continuavam reclamando da vida
continuavam infelizes nos mesmos lugares
em que ela enfim estavam reclamando isso
e consumir muito eu me incomodava com
isso porque o mundo corporativo com todo
seu glamour com jatinho particular com a
capa da revista com o milionário se ou
antes dos trinta aquilo pra mim tem um
significado tão grande eu ia ser esse
cara na minha cabeça era uma questão de
tempo pra você e eu adorava o mundo
corporativo achava aquilo glamour eu
construísse amor e aspas pelo mundo
corporativo pela minha carreira eu
comecei muito novinho vim com 12 anos
vendendo perito na escola era muito bom
porque o feto era baixo a procura é
grande mas é muito cedo se empreende
aprende o mercado regulado não pode
competir com cantina e aí você sabe
disso e vai pro outro ramo falar
exatamente isso deu certo vou pra
automotivo começa a lavar carros nos 14
anos e era apaixonado por carros eu
tenho uma enfim
adoro gravar carros e tudo mais e eu com
16 anos realizou um sonho dos maiores
sonhos da minha vida era ter um carinho
na carteira de trabalho
eu consegui meu primeiro emprego formal
aos 16 anos entrei numa metalúrgica
sou daqui da zona norte de são paulo e
pra mim trabalhar de novo é uma coisa
muito legal e tudo mais e eu com 17 anos
entrei na escola técnica e no mundo das
multinacionais em trabalho a empresa
suíça e já com 19 anos eu estava mais do
que realizado
estava trabalhando em uma montadora de
automóveis que meu nome inteiro e roger
friis verba o que eu gostava de carros
eu tinha trabalhado volks wagen enfim
encontrar uma empresa que prestava
serviço para volkswagen falei poxa
questão de tempo vou trabalhar por aí
tudo mais
tudo ia muito bem eu tava muito jovem
com uma carreira já consolidada eu
estava com meus 20 para 21 anos como
supervisor de engenharia de uma fábrica
de motores da fiat em betim e ganhava
bem tinha um carro novo viajava para o
exterior saltaram de paraquedas mas
também tudo muito legal até que
aconteceu um evento que no rio de
janeiro como todo início de ano existem
as enchentes nem os desmoronamentos
só que nesse ano foi mais grave em 2011
916 pessoas morreram e mais de 35 mil
ficaram desalojadas e eu não tinha feito
nenhum tipo de trabalho voluntário muito
enfim sistematicamente na minha vida e
minha namorada vez a reportagem do g1
dizendo que belo horizonte estava
morando lá na época estava recebendo
doações para mandar pro rio de janeiro
vamos lá né levar uma cesta básica
pronto eu só vendo gente vai seguir bem
na vida
fomos lá é e aí a gente foi levar os
mantimentos que a gente prometeu e
aquela operação da cruz vermelha está
uma bagunça
eu trabalhava organizando o processo de
produção puxa vida tá bagunçado
organismo processos
vamos organizar essa trabalho da cruz
vermelha ea gente passou que era para
ser uma simples ida e volta passei todo
final de semana junto com minha namorada
ajudando a organizar aquela operação da
cruz vermelha e foi incrível foi uma
operação muito intensa de mão na massa
de pegar coisa do chão arrumar fazer
bancadas layouts e tudo mais o que
aconteceu na sexta feira eu fazia parte
dos 13% na segunda feira era o mais
desmotivado funcionário que a fiat já
tinha visto
eu detestava naquele momento trabalhar
com automóveis eu achava que estava
prejudicando mundo cada grama de co2 que
emite achava que era minha culpa eu
falei ferro
agora preciso salvar o mundo tudo que
era a causa
enfim me encantava me sensibiliza vá
causa dos idosos
crianças a questão do racismo igualdade
de gênero eqüidade de gênero tudo isso
me deixava muito paranóico
só que aí surge uma lei política
nacional de resíduos sólidos no
finalzinho de 2010 que falava sobre
logística reversa repuxando descrever
seu negócio que eu sei fazer
trabalhava com logística organização de
processos
vamos estudar um pouquinho mais sobre
essa linha e não demorou muito para eu
cair no assunto catadores de materiais
recicláveis e quem é esse cara nunca
ouvi falar vamos descobrir quem são
esses catadores em descobrir que o lixo
é um problema que tem um aspecto
econômico muito grave são 10 bilhões de
reais desperdiçados todos os anos na
ferramenta de resíduos um problema
social de um milhão de pessoas que
trabalham em condições bem peculiares em
arriscadas de trabalho
é nessa causa da catação de materiais
recicláveis e uma questão ambiental o
óbvio né
pela quantidade de recursos naturais que
são demandadas ilegal tem uma causa bem
completinho aí né pra trabalhar
só que tem uma coisa que me motiva mais
do que a causa propriamente dita os
primeiros catadores que eu conversei na
rua carroceiros né
existe uma motivação que era diferente
diferente do que a gente imagina que as
pessoas geralmente são tristes
coitadinhos e tudo mais mas vários deles
mostravam uma felicidade que estava
fazendo que eu não ver no mundo
corporativo pra mim era o correto
esse cara tem alguma coisa que tem
alguma coisa diferente no trabalho dessa
pessoa que faz ela ser motivada e isso
me incentivou e pesquisando cada vez
mais
percebi então que muitos desses
catadores são organizados sob a forma de
cooperativas
outra coisa que eu não conhecia não
sabia o que era resolvi estudar um
pouquinho mais e fui entender que a
cooperativa foi um dos movimentos de
resposta à revolução industrial assim
como o comunismo e do sindicalismo
cooperativismo surgiu como uma resposta
enfim o anseio de alguns trabalhadores
de se auto organizar em pré venda em
escala vender melhor na frente às
grandes corporações e indústrias eo
cooperativismo que foi em 1844
foi feito o primeiro modelo que deu
certo pelos pioneiros de rochdale na
inglaterra é um movimento que por mais
que no brasil a gente não conhecia muito
um dom de pessoas no mundo está
diretamente relacionado a uma
cooperativa e membro de uma cooperativa
um em cada sete pessoas
somente as 300 maiores cooperativas do
mundo geram 2 trilhões de dólares em
receitas ea organização internacional do
trabalho diz que é um dos mais
resilientes modelos de negócio época de
crise
foi legal cooperativa ilegal
os catadores são legais a questão do
lixo é legal
a cooperativa então em uma empresa uma
sociedade em que as pessoas vêm antes do
capital
então o interesse na empresa com fins
lucrativos m3 com fins de pessoas
baseada em valores valores cooperativos
e quando eu li isso pela primeira vez e
não é o valor de uma cooperativa é o
valor da doutrina cooperativa eu percebi
que um monte de problemas com o mundo
corporativo mas eu não conhecia
auto-ajuda responsabilidade democracia
igualdade equidade solidariedade eram
coisas que eu não via no mundo
corporativo e de repente se tornou como
eu vivi sem isso durante toda a minha
carreira
de repente se tornou tudo tão
obrigatório
eu preciso trabalhar nesse modelo é
preciso fazer isso aqui dá certo e aí
foi uma questão de combinação de peças
já tinha causa do lixo dos resíduos dos
catadores a questão ambiental tinha
experiência no mundo corporativo da
eficiência do método mundo corporativo
não é de todo ruim
tem muitas coisas boas pela que eu
aprendi e esse modelo de negócio que no
brasil ele vai meio mal né
será que ele não consegue colocar tudo
isso junto no pacote
foi aí que surgiu a idéia de empreender
é o green programa cooperativa que
presta diferentes serviços na cadeia de
resíduos desde o diagnóstico
conscientização coleta seletiva e
triagem de resíduos e logística reversa
que é o que iniciou toda a história
então a gente já tem um caso de sucesso
o modelo já estudado para ser replicado
é fora da nossa unidade e o que achei
que ia ficar triste né porque agora está
na base da pirâmide agora a gente estava
sofrendo e tudo mais
tive que virar catador e para montar
isso chamei várias pessoas que eram
muito próximos de mim amigas e um monte
de gente entrou nesse bolo tinha catador
tinha amigo tinha gente tinha faculdade
a gente que a faculdade a dona de casa a
gente fundou a cooperativa já começou a
trabalhar com condomínios empresariais
em são paulo clubes esportivos
multinacionais que começou bem pequeno
em que iria começar com uma organização
gigantesca neco mil metros quadrados 90
catadores começamos em 70 metros
quadrados sete catadores e foi crescendo
nessas condições a gente já tinha uma
produtividade que era três vezes maior
do que as cooperativas que já estavam
instrumentalizadas com todos
equipamentos ea gente entendeu que isso
era o resgate da essência do
cooperativismo nosso modelo de negócio
bem a gente cresceu o gol com já foi
para um outro lugar que a gente
novamente construiu a sede da
cooperativa e eu me tornei então por que
eu chamo de cooperativistas
essa minha outra profissão além de
catador que a gente percebeu que com
isso a gente tinha feito com várias
pessoas olhando estudando o modelo que a
gente desenhou a gente resolver um outro
problema além da questão do lixo assim
como a revolução industrial em 2011
tiveram as ocupações ocupações de wall
street
o paço enfim no mundo inteiro vários
jovens estavam ocupando praças e foi a
ocasião de visitar um fórum de economia
solidária em que eu estive nessa
ocupação de wall street e ouvir de novo
várias pessoas insatisfeitas com o
modelo capitalista em que nós estávamos
ficando ambas negócio tão bom né pra
todo mundo capitalismo e ao mesmo tempo
ninguém gosta todo mundo quer falar que
é 99% 99% e assim como naquela época
sindicalismo comunismo e cooperativismo
saíram como respostas vem o filósofo
australiano diz não é bem por aí
hoje em dia as pessoas entendem trabalho
como algo muito maior do que o dinheiro
elas acham que aliás podem se sentirem
preenchidas né
sendo uma das maiores razões satisfação
no trabalho não é o dinheiro é autonomia
e aí as pessoas não querem mais
trabalhar em grandes empresas
principalmente os jovens
eles querem abrir future startups fazer
bolo de casamento
- trabalhei em grandes empresas porque
nossa senhora trabalhando em grande
empresa alguma coisa errada com você não
tem propósito que a gente percebeu que
nem todas as profissões encaixam nesse
novo anseio nem todo mundo consegue
abrir uma startup de será montado
bilhões sendo montada avião embraer fez
isso mas hoje é grande só monta aviões
porque é grande e como é que a gente
consegue encaixar tudo isso a gente acha
que com as pessoas que têm autonomia
quatro coisas que a gente pode fazer
para resolver esse dilema que parece um
impasse
a primeira coisa é reconhecer as pessoas
pela função social que elas comprem que
é muito além do simples
parabéns bom trabalho porque você abriu
a porta para mim que conhecer
verdadeiramente as pessoas não tomando
como certos modelos de sucesso então o
artista se o presidente são pessoas que
deram certo
a partir do momento em que você diz que
essas pessoas deram certo
por definição todas as outras deram
errado e como você quer um modelo em que
100% das pessoas estão engajadas sendo
que 13% deu certo e 87% errado
não dá pra conseguir motivação assim a
partir do momento que a gente reconhecer
o trabalho do catador do porteiro da
copeira da enfermeira do professor do
gari das profissões mais essenciais à
vida humana e por mais que bill gates
tenha dito que elas serão substituídas
acho que vai demorar um pouco
eu acho que aí a gente vai conseguir ter
uma sociedade com menos suicídios e com
mais motivação
a outra questão é valorizar a
participação de todos que estão ao seu
lado sejam seus subordinados colaterais
ou superiores onde você está trabalhando
todos nós somos seres pensantes todos
nós temos a capacidade de raciocinar de
gerar idéias de emoções e enfim
raciocínio para algum fim vamos
aproveitar isso vamos desperdiçar e do
outro lado se um funcionário não
desperdice nenhum
uma oportunidade de participação da
caixinha de sugestões amb deposite idéia
é um bate papo com o chefe é um email
você pode mandar alguém não desperdice a
sua capacidade de participação e por
último inspire se no modelo cooperativo
ele está comprovadamente funcionando no
mundo inteiro e vários negócios podem e
dessa fonte para melhorar as relações
que tem com seus empregados e
funcionários nem meu convite que nós
tenhamos uma vida com cada vez menos
trabalho tripalium torturante e cada vez
com mais trabalho cooperativo isso só
depende de nós
obrigado